on this Saturday night stepping down
after stunning allegations around
foreign interference why in Ontario PC
government caucus member has resigned
while rejecting the claims against him
if he choose his evil ideology shielding
performers from protests with multiple
happening every week why there's a sharp
rise in hate against the queer community
and from who the gender gap in Health
Data you're going to end up with a
biased algorithm and how it's skewing
artificial intelligence research
you and I
and the Canadian nominee that's my
favorite thing about working animation
hoping to strike Oscar gold once again
[Music]
for a Nasser reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments surrounding a
global news investigation into
allegations of foreign interference in
Canada's 2019 federal election Ontario
Premier Doug Ford says he's supporting
Vincent Ka who was a member of Ford's
Progressive conservative government
until he opted out last night choosing
to sit as an independent this follows
bombshell allegations from intelligent
sources that Ka was part of a covert
network helping to advance beijing's
agenda in Canada Vincent Ka says he is
stepping away from the progressive
conservative caucus in order to dedicate
his time to clearing his name and
representing his constituents a
spokesperson for Doug Ford told Global
News while the allegations against Mr Ka
are not proven they're serious and
deserve his full and undivided attention
as he works to clear his name a third
parliamentary committee has now opened
its own investigation into foreign
interference David Aiken has our top
story tonight
one of the best mpps around when he won
his Toronto area riding in the Ontario
provincial election of 2018
Vincent Copp became the first immigrant
from mainland China to take a seat at
Queen's Park the member for Don Valley
North I Delight to take this opportunity
but sources in Canada's Federal
intelligence Community have told global
news that coup was also part of an
alleged foreign interference Network to
advance the political agenda of the
government in Beijing and that he was
provided with fifty thousand dollars to
do that work cook said such allegations
are nonsense Force acquisition this is
Luis is I told him in the email already
you say it's racist it's racist because
I was born in China because I come from
China but many in Canada's Chinese
communities support more aggressive
action by Ottawa to confront the regime
in Beijing I believe that the government
should take a stronger message and also
take a stronger stance even while
cautioning those pushing for Boulder
action not to Fan the Flames of
anti-chinese racism the notion that all
ethnic Chinese communities are supporter
of the Chinese authorities is racist and
reductive Quan and Wong testified Friday
at the House of Commons Ethics Committee
it's the third parliamentary committee
that is looking at foreign interference
by China in Canada's Affairs another
committee is focused specifically on
Election interference and the National
Security and intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians which meets behind
closed doors is examining information
collected by Canada's national security
agencies it is important that we explain
to Canadians how it is that we are
putting in place the measures that our
agencies use to address and mitigate
against foreign interference the work of
parliamentarians will complement that of
the special Rapport tour prime minister
Justin Trudeau has promised to appoint
to look into all of this no government
has taken more concrete action than ours
when it comes to fighting against
foreign interference one of the
rapporteur's jobs will be to advise the
government as to whether a full-blown
public inquiry is required and we will
abide by their recommendation but the
Prime Minister has not yet said when
that rapporture will be appointed or who
it will be David Akin Global News
Ottawa
there is some turbulence over at Flair
Airlines four of the company's planes
are no longer operational after a U.S
Leasing Company sees them in a
commercial dispute a source tells Global
News the low-cost Canadian Airline was
apparently days behind on payments worth
one million dollars to lesser Airborne
Capital it was also given prior notice
that Airborne wanted to terminate leases
on the four planes a statement by Flair
says payment has been initiated and that
it's engaged in mediation to remedy the
situation it's also activated three
spare aircraft to make up for
disruptions
a day after one of the largest bank
failures in American history forced
Washington to intervene there are
growing concerns for a potential
spillover effect when markets open on
Monday after more than 40 Years of
operation Silicon Valley Bank a leading
lender for Tech startups ran short on
cash due as Reggie jackini explains it's
left customers unsure if they'll have
access to their money it took only a
matter of hours for the 16th largest
bank in the United States to go from
staple ground to underwater I'm pretty
concerned Silicon Valley Bank was a
go-to in the tech World Decades of
experience turned it into a leading
lender for startups now it's sudden and
abrupt downfall has dropped billions in
Investments and deposits a little
nerve-wracking when it comes down to how
you keep operating your company the
concern started midweek when in need of
assets the bank sold off bonds but at a
loss its capital shrank and resulted in
the beginnings of a bank run by Friday
Federal Regulators swooped in to provide
Financial guardrails that's what they
were doing was protecting the deposit
and then they have a way to unwind the
rest that could throw a wrench into some
company's finances if they're unable to
access money beyond the insured 250
thousand dollars
when Banks experience Financial losses
it is and should be a matter of concern
before the dust could settle markets
were rattled and sell-offs could bleed
into Monday blame is being partially
laid on high interest rates with the FED
now walking a tightrope on the one hand
they're trying to tame inflation and in
the process they might tip the economy
into a recession at the same time we
have this emerging Financial
instability risk this is the largest
bank failure since the 2008 crisis and
while Niche Banks tied to one sector may
feel stress major institutions are
likely to avoid catastrophic loss the
reforms that were put in a place back
then really provide the kind of
resilience that we'd like to see Silicon
Valley Bank did have operations in
Canada and the big Banks felt the
squeeze erasing nearly 20 billion
dollars in value on Friday many of them
have acquired Regional banks in the U.S
increasing exposure to this bank's
failure neither Reggie zucchini in
Washington thanks Reggie there was
another round of contention over
family-friendly drag events in this
country today in New Brunswick a large
group of counter protesters in support
of drag performers and
lgbtq2s plus rights faced off with a
much smaller rally opposing drag story
time events it happened outside an event
at the Moncton Library where organizers
receive dangerous threats online ahead
of the event these drag performances
have become frequent targets of hatred
and backlash as Heather urik's West
reports it's happening as far-right
attacks on the community seem to be on
the rise
why can't boys wear skirts and bracelets
and nail polish Jesse asked the boys
launched in Calgary in 2018 reading with
royalty has seen drag kings and queens
read stories about inclusion to children
but in recent months events like these
have faced opposition and protest it
comes and goes and waves but since I
would say about November we've just had
it weekend after weekend and it's
getting stronger if he choose his evil
ideology it's not just Calgary the
us-based armed conflict location and
event data project has been tracking
anti-lgbtq2 protests across North
America in the U.S the increase has been
striking with a number of demonstrations
nearly tripling in 2022 the group says
the rise in Canada is slower but numbers
in this country are trending upwards as
well we're seeing protests against the
lgbtq plus Community occurring across
Canada right now with multiple happening
every week so what exactly is going on
the Canadian anti-hate Network says
there has been a pivot by far-right
movements around the globe from covet
conspiracy theories to a narrative
involving the lgbtq2 community
sexualizing children is totally wrong
it's the most wrong thing of all it's
the same age-old conspiracy theory that
queer people are our pedophiles and are
coming after your children they're just
rehashing it and use it against the
trans Community online space is that
once supported Canada's Freedom Convoy
against covet restrictions are now
filled with transphobic memes if you
don't like drag queen Story Time simply
don't go but to go up and protest and
take away somebody else's safe space
their own sense of community
you know is not only irresponsible it's
incredibly dangerous
Calgary police have charged a man with
hate related crimes after he showed
homophobic slurs at a library event
they're also investigating a gun threat
made towards the queer Community within
that Community people feel under attack
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
on This Day in 2020 the World Health
Organization officially deemed the
covid-19 outbreak a pandemic three years
later it remains a global threat with
public health emergencies in place
across dozens of countries there have
been significant milestones in vaccines
and therapies but despite widespread
immunity the who still considers covid a
public health emergency of international
concern doctors say part of the issue
stems from a lack of understanding about
how kovid started because data and
intelligence gets tied up in politics
we have to admit that the billions of
dollars we've invested in the last 20
years
and the millions of people that we have
trained in public health and built
Laboratories around the world did not
prevent this pandemic and we have seven
million people dead so let's just admit
that what we thought we had done failed
us and let's fix it
there is unanimous support among U.S
lawmakers to release classified
information to better understand this
Health crisis governments are also being
urged to regulate research keep data
accessible and spend more on public
health to better prepare for another
virus
artificial intelligence can be a
powerful tool in the health care sector
synthesizing large amounts of data to
spot new trends all the while helping
doctors make informed and educated
decisions but when it comes to
information about women and their own
personal health experts say there's a
gap Catherine Ward explains
if we don't do the research we won't
have those answers effective Medical
Treatments rely on good information and
that's key to developing AI models says
expert Ashley cassavin if you're putting
bad data into uh into the system then
you're going to get a bad outcome a bad
outcome would be an inaccurate answer to
what the diagnosis should be Dr Thalia
Fields says women are not well
represented in medical research the
proportions of people who have the
disease in reality are not reflected by
the proportions of people who are in the
clinical trial data from the Heart and
Stroke Foundation of Canada Echoes this
finding according to a recent report
two-thirds of participants in clinical
trials on heart disease and stroke have
been men when women are included
researchers don't always analyze the
data by sex and gender we need to
account for both biological differences
which may be related to hormones and
anatomy and body compositions there are
many reasons why women are not well
represented Sometimes women may not be
able to take time from caring for
elderly parents or caring for children
or due to issues with their work to be
able to get a way to participate in
study follow-ups the paper further
explains conditions that are more common
or serious in women but rare in men
typically get less attention with
artificial intelligence being used more
widely in medicine from trying to
predict drug use outcomes or helping
doctors decide if chemotherapy would be
useful having good data is critical
because an algorithm can only learn from
the information it's been given so if
there are biases in the data that go
into training the algorithm you're going
to end up with a biased algorithm
experts say addressing this data Gap is
critical so Advanced tools like AI are
relevant and trustworthy regardless of a
patient's gender Catherine Ward Global
News Toronto
Rising floods and fears coming up rounds
of deadly storms as thousands evacuate
in California
foreign
is under a state of emergency tonight
two people are dead and some ten
thousand people have been forced to flee
their homes as catastrophic flooding
triggered by another Fierce winter storm
washes through the Golden State rivers
are overflowing communities cut off this
latest atmospheric river is dumping
torrential rain and even more snow on a
state that is still desperately trying
to dig out from a series of powerful
storms and warming temperatures in the
days ahead could exacerbate the flooding
as the Sierra Nevada snowpack begins to
melt
to Italy now where the country's Coast
Guard has rescued more than 1300
migrants Crossing the sea overnight
the migrants were brought ashore after
three separate operations that began on
Friday on multiple vessels overloaded
with people off Italy's southern coast
one boat was found to have been carrying
around 500 people alone the rescues come
weeks after the Italian Coast Guard face
criticism over the deaths of 74 migrants
in a shipwreck around the same region
[Music]
ahead the unlikely path for an Alberta
music star set to take the Juno stage
the best and brightest talents in Canada
will be at the judos this Monday in
Edmonton many of whom you probably
already know but on the new reality this
weekend we met an up-and-coming artist
you may not know but probably should
Mike drolet has more on a finale whose
path to the Judo stage was anything but
easy
me somewhere
Abby is
not a household name his voice in deeply
personal songwriting is turning heads
thanks to his debut album and anthemic
single Nomads but his journey to the
Juno stage is even more powerful
[Music]
he's OG kri from the Sandy Lake first
nation in Northern Ontario he grew up
off the grid with only a guitar to keep
him busy he dreamed of a career in music
but to make ends meet he took a job as a
surveyor for a Mining Company
on a cold February day he was
snowshoeing by himself over a frozen
River when the ice cracked
that was the moment his life changed
forever
multiple family members that had had
froze to death and I was just like what
am I doing with my life like what is
this where it ends like like doing this
job I don't care about like I didn't
even get to try to do anything I wanted
to do with my life how long after that
did you quit I had a plane ticket and I
was gone in three months he moved to
Toronto where he eventually applied for
the international indigenous music
Summit
the music that finally got him noticed
is intensely personal inspired by his
grandfather's memories of residential
schools when the summit's founders hit
play on his video submission they were
floored we both were just like who is
this how have we never seen this or
heard this before it just stopped us in
our tracks you know it just had that
quality of
it yeah got me in my solar plexus you
know am I losing myself
[Music]
now signed to the record label ishkide
asanabi's schedule has very few holes in
it he's booked for shows not only in
Canada and the US but throughout Europe
is your life a whirlwind right now yeah
yeah we're looking at the schedule and
like it's insane like it's I think I'll
I might get some time
in late September
[Laughter]
that's down the road right now the focus
is the junos where Ace and Abbey will
not only perform but could potentially
win his first award Mike draw like
Global News Toronto
Mike will have more on his remarkable
story on the new reality tonight at 7 pm
here on global
next meet the Canadian Oscar hopeful
whose latest film is up for gold
[Music]
the Academy Awards are tomorrow and a
few talented Canadian filmmakers are
nominated for the prestigious golden
statues among them Ontario Rey's
director Chris Williams for his animated
movie The Sea Beast it wouldn't be his
first Oscar nod though as far NASA
reports he's already had a hand in
animating many beloved classics
a swashbuckling Adventure filled with
sea monsters Cutthroat hunters and a lot
of heart can I take a photo of course
yeah all from the mind of Canadian
American filmmaker Chris Williams
director of the oscar-nominated animated
movie The Sea Beast very nice to meet
you very nice to meet you we caught up
with Williams ahead of a special
screening of the film back in his
hometown of Kitchener Ontario where he
first Drew inspiration as a young
Storyteller when I was very young my dad
bought me a camera and I started making
little stop motion films and I just was
desperate to create stories and express
myself and and when I started seeing
movies like King Kong and Raiders of
Lost Ark and Star Wars those big broad
adventure stories that captivated me now
a veteran at the animation industry he
spent 25 years at Walt Disney Animation
Studios where he helped create many of
their beloved characters
[Music]
a world you know and he's no stranger to
Awards Glory either Williams directed
the superhero adventure Big Hero 6 a hit
at the box office in 2014. going on to
NAB his first Oscar for best animated
film Big Hero 6 is a really good movie
I've watched it before I've actually
watched it twice in
with his latest feature on Netflix
Williams has now set sail Beyond
Disney's Enchanted Castle on his own
putting a new spin on a well-known
setting you and I have a different idea
of cute
though the Sea Beast revolves around a
classic Ocean Adventure it features a
more diverse cast of characters and
tackles tough themes all too familiar to
adults like the power of disinformation
and the violence that can follow this
was a course on media literacy
honestly some of these entrenched ideas
you need to look at them examine them a
little closer and and not just accept at
face value everything that you're told
and so yeah that was something that we
definitely explored with the film as to
how the story's crew of Roughnecks face
those issues he believes the answer is
distinctly Canadian I think it's
something that is more Universal across
Canada a sense of community a sense that
people are going to look out for each
other that organism that is the crew
they're very reliant on each other right
they each of them have to do their job
and do it well for their very survival
the whole industry has gotten bigger and
bigger in making Sea Beast Williams
worked with many artists based in Canada
inspiring younger animators to join the
ranks love creating an art in general I
like telling a story so I thought
animation would be a good way to go into
that because that's the best way can
make someone move make someone have
feelings emotions oscar-winning director
and as they follow his path into the
Rough Waters of movie making he's got
one important piece of advice
no one person could explain to you how
an anime and how an animated movie gets
made right we are so dependent on each
other and I actually really love that
that's my favorite thing about working
animation
Global News
[Music]
professional for this Saturday night I'm
nitu Garcia tonight's Air Canada is a
vibrant view of Vancouver at night
thanks for watching hope to see you
again tomorrow have a great night